he's making it look good how about this hatrick
overtime game winner you could see he was even
like you kidding me with that pass clearing
pass fails good Brans it into the slot left
wing scores tick tac toe and the Russian three
you can see off the right side of your screen
Marko's gone blue jacket is doing a good job of
standing in zone he's going to set up here again
had a quick start to this one and boy Marko
could not have a better start [Music] deser
dumps one ahead hoping Miller can get there
first he does he scores what a play by Brock
besser to angle that one off the cornerboards
Miller there puts it home in the backand and
the Canucks have a two nothing lead Miller's in
behind everybody right up top backhand chip two
goals for the Canucks two Power Play Goals
for the Canucks here's barzel quick turn to
the board barzel opens up doson doson cruising
back go doson to his back end Waits and waits
gets past the golender gets past the Checker open
it up okay I'll zip it up over in the right hand
side great goal for Noah doson great pass from
Matthew barzel here's Crosby stepping ahead of
the pack drops it for L tank backand or score
absolutely sick from the Pittsburgh Penguins
just a great poke to Crosby who's off and eyes in
the back of his head senses going off like crazy
it's like he knows where Chris L Tang is he knows
where everybody is Josh you could see he was even
like you kidding me with that pass Marner trying
to Spring knce here's n indeep b Matthew scor well
Matthew n taking advantage of the opportunity to
play with 34 and 16 and he's making it look good
how about this a quick little stop up and no look
pass and a quick slide through the five hole mat
you saying to the fans get up on your feet quick
Outland and up the ice comes aimont aimont up
the Middle St what a go here comes aimont up the
middle he wants a pass it back and he's actually
trying to make a play into the middle of the ice
and he's getting knocked down in the backand and
it ends up going top shell terrific second
effort from Mikey aont that's what he's all
about ball back in has wallr he trick the The
N he scores what a play for Oliver W watch the
move get it to the forehead bang right up in
the top hand corner in the toy tremendous goal
from Oliver W that's the ability that this young
player has Matthews now with a hatrick hatrick
SOA shot with n causing a commotion in front
ni tied up Matthews gets it the Marner sliding
it through a little dish pass by Matthews a
knock down by n good hard work getting into
the tough areas of the ice and then quick hands
in front to knock it down and get it up and over
Johansson got to go they had a man Advantage
here got to go Mavis now turns it into a
two-on-one with Terry Mason Mavis to Terry
scor hatrick overtime game winner from Mavis
right here watch him look off schz and then
away he goes see you later two on one good
pass that is just one beautiful finish from
him after that solo Dash by Fabian zerland
here's Pon at the offensive Blue Line cuts
across and feeds Susi nice pass but C scores
Carson Susi put it on the tap after Patterson's
able to Bobble a puck off the blade of a stick
move it across an odd man Rush turns into the
fifth goal of the hockey game for the conuts
JJ Moser leading the rush over the line it goes
kolie is in kie scores Logan [__] and a beauty
first in the National Hockey League for 92 the
separation see you later Logan kulie the pass
again JJ Moser backhand forehand roof job what a
set of midies now a chance with a minute left in
the power play for the Rangers p up from the score
Chris krider on a beautiful setup from ouri panan
quickly developing it's a two-on-one chadfield
goes down he gets beat five hole that's as good
of a passer as there is in the game this laa had
a great training camp here's marer scores Mitch
Marner Far Side along the ice and the Maple Leafs
are on the board and then what a pass by by Austin
Matthews and then the shot might even hit Matthews
or definitely deflected in front just like that
you're back into the game sandine on the go tried
to split the Defenders Wilson there to help his
dri go Tom Wilson on a rolling biscuit gives the
Caps a one- nothing lead the more you watch that
the more amazed you are that puck was bouncing
all over the place Wilson stick handled it once
on a hop and shot it off the Hop to get Washington
un front ptra closes and wow what a goal scorers
move right there the Poise and the confidence in
the finish by Matt ptra but the play was made out
by the point the Bruins keep the play alive and
it was Shad Kirk who makes a nice little feed to
padra after he rotates off that right point to the
middle of the offensive zone there's the Finishing
Touch K the boot either good play by Thompson
he's going to have a partial Breakaway Thompson
takes the shot scores trono just very Reckless
with the puck here this whole power play to this
point eventually T Thomson takes advantage of it
picks up that turnover goes in takes the initial
shot there's the save made but it's laying right
there and momentum just carries it in back comes
forg trying to answer WRA around score O'Reilly's
going to get it to forsberg here on the outside
he's got speed watch this fake right here to get
him to bite just that little quick little shift
to the middle looks like he's going to go to the
middle Campbell goes down and then now all is he
has to do is come around the post that's not easy
to do to get that puck to go back in what a play
there by Philip forsberg for second goal on the
season eel walking in shot score in and out of
the back of the net just like that oh my Theodore
drives the net takes two Defenders EO leans in and
that is upstairs over the left shoulder in and out
of the net what a release what a shot by eel Miko
rer knocked down in front Reinhard and barov after
go Sasha barov in front there's the shot from the
point that's exactly what you want Total Chaos and
then the big strength of bark off look at he just
out battles rinsky for the positioning and then
slides that backand right over the goal line now
Rasmus doen at Center makes one move gains the
line off the boards to himself takes a shot scor
here's darene is in a position he just soft chips
his pass everybody and he gets the puck he's under
pressure by Burns takes the quick shot the puck
goes perfectly just inside that POS you talk about
all the defenseman he want around the League this
guy is as good as anybody as PKA tries to work
around traffic he's knocked to the ice no arms
going up at this point front scores Alex tuck this
is JJ P powering his way in he's going to play
this Puck to the front of the net Alex Tak able
to poke that one away in the same motion as he
pokes it away bang the puck hits the ground took
it right off of Seth Jarvis's stick and he takes
the shot and he able to put it past ramp beautiful
play right there by Alex to lightning put it
across to headman headman back pass up head to
aimos and aimont battles and gets it towards the
Ed here he comes sharp angle shot scores did that
that gets in he got it up and over the shoulder
of Jake Allen what a shot by Mikey acon that's go
no Jake Allen misplayed that one now this one from
an impossible Angle now the lightning are [Music]
flying